this is the F2 sent to us in sponsored
by go tracks and I'm convinced that it's
one of the best budget e-bikes you can
buy in 2023 for three main reasons the
first one is the price now I know that
sounds a little bit cliche but you'll
see what I'm talking about when I get
into the features and to be honest this
is a really great deal MSRP is for a
thousand dollars but using the link in
the description or pin comment only 800
with the coupon code that is an absolute
killer value because reason number two
is the twist throttle that comes on an
e-bike as low budget as this which is
really impressive and I love using it
because sometimes you're on your bike
and you get a little bit tired after
riding for a while you just want to
chill relax your legs leave them there
and just use the twist throttle that
goes up to 20 miles per hour by itself
and I even did some off-roading uphill
on gravel this thing was able to pull me
by itself without using the petals at
all that was very very impressive and
this is just such a big deal because
there are other e-bikes that are more
expensive than this one and they don't
even come with a Twist throttle and it's
so surprising and before I get into the
main reason number three I do want to do
kind of like a walk through of the specs
and features of this bike first now one
thing I really love is the fat tires
they are 20 inch by three inch wide and
it's really nice to have them because it
makes the whole experience really smooth
and solid you feel like you're grounded
like you might not fall over like some
other e-bikes that have those skinny
little tires it's very premium to have
those and they feel really great soft
and comfortable I also like that they
have the fenders
pre-installed so that way if it's a
little bit rainy a little bit wet you're
not going to get splashing dirt all over
your back and right next to the fenders
you'll also see the built-in light which
is great for those nighttime rides maybe
you're commuting from work back home
it's nice to have that very easy to turn
on we also have suspension right here
which works extremely well and this
really helps for those off road times
when you're riding the bike and I was
doing some off-roading on some rocks it
was pretty hard but it helped a lot with
the suspension now making our way up
here to The Handlebar I really love that
you have these kind of flaps that hold
your palm so your palm can rest there
without getting very tired right here
you have your controls to turn on the
display of the e-bike and go through the
Pas systems from zero to five That's How
Strong the passive assist pedal assist
is going to work for you so that's nice
that it has both pedal assist and the
throttle you could use whichever one
you're comfortable with or you can even
just rely on the bike controls seven
speeds if you want a little bit of a
challenge and a workout and I like how
you have this kind of control here where
you have the button to basically just
cycle through the gears I like the
display setup you have your speed your
energy bar which is basically your
battery life and the impressive thing
about this e-bike for the price for 800
it's got 40 miles which lasts a very
long time now as far as the motor specs
we have a 500 watt motor which is very
good and strong enough to get you up
some good Hills we also have disc brakes
both the front and the back I like this
little storage section right here you
can put on a box whatever you have your
bag going to work tie it up that's very
nice to have I also really like how the
seat is nice wide very soft comfortable
and you have tool free adjustments right
here now the one thing that's really
cool about this e-bike in getting into
reason number three is you'll see this
little stand at the bottom and you might
be wondering why is this white little
stand there well that's because this is
a folding e-bike yes it folds right here
with these controls just pushes forward
pull it back it'll fold in half and then
you can even fold the handlebar down and
the crazy thing about this is that I
took this e-bike here on the smallest
model that Tesla makes yes the model 3
in the trunk this e-bike actually fits
so that just basically makes it so much
more convenient because you can take
this anywhere in basically any car you
could even take this in the back of a
pickup truck and it barely uses any
space compared to a lot of other
mountain bikes that take up a massive
amount of space so you can fit a lot
more stuff in the back of your pickup
this is just one of the biggest
convenience factors for me and you might
be wondering where is the battery
because you don't see it here well it's
actually built in right here into the
frame so when you unfold it you just use
your key unlock it pull it out and you
could actually take it with you inside
your house and plug it into charge or
you could also just remove this little
rubber grommet and plug it in directly
like this so you don't even have to
touch it just so much flexibility with
this e-bike and lastly to kind of wrap
this all up if you've never tried an
e-bike it is an absolute blast just the
pure joy of pulling this twist throttle
and just going at 20 miles an hour is an
amazing feeling and once again the great
thing is that the barrier to entry is
very low only 800 right now using the
link below it's an absolute steal of a
deal so everything wrapped up with a 500
watt motor The Twist throttle the
folding ability the fat tires fenders
everything put together it's a killer
steal of a deal at 800 so hopefully you
enjoy this review let me know what you
think about it down in the comment
section below click the button above to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you